[موسيقى]
هذه مشاهد لاكبر عرض عسكري في بولندا منذ
الحرب البارده رسائل في اتجاهين تحاول
الحكومه تمريرها
الاتجاه الاول طمانه الداخل قبل انتخابات
مقرره في اكتوبر تشرين الاول المقبل اما
الاتجاه الثاني فهو استعراض عضلات امام
الجارين المزعجين في الشرق روسيا
وبيلاروسيا
الاستعراض الذي اقيم في الذكرى 103
لانتصار بولندا على الاتحاد السوفيتي في
معركه وارسو شمل الفي جنديا من بولندا
ودول الناتو الاخرى يسيرون في العاصمه
برفقه 200 قطعه من المعدات العسكريه
واثنتين وتسعين طائره السياق الزمني لهذا
الاستعراض هو الجانب الاكثر خطوره وفق ما
تراه مراكز ابحاث غربيه اذ سبقه تحشيد
عسكري هو الاكبر وتقاذف للتهامات والوعيد
وارث اتهمت مينسك باستخدام 100 عنصر من
قوات فاجنر الروسيه الى حدودها اما
بيلاروسيا فردت بتصريحات ساخره ترى
بولندا تعد من اكثر الدول تاثرا بحرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا في عام 2022 رفعت
انفاقها العسكري الى نحو اربعه عشر مليار
دولار وابرمت صفقه لشراء 32 مقاتله
امريكيه من طراز 35 اما الخطه التاليه
لحكومه بلاشتاك فهي ان تصبح البلاد اقوى
قوات بريه في اوروبا وبالفعل بدات هذه
الخطه ترى النور تدريجيا فبحسب تقرير
لصحيفه بوليتيكو فان بولندا باتت تمتلك
دبابات ومدافع اكثر من المانيا وسيتجاوز
عدد عناصر الجيش وضباطه 350 الف جندي
بحلول عام 2005
على الجهه الاخرى تبدو بيلاروسيا غريم
بولندا المباشر اقل قوه من حيث العديد
والعتاد فمنذ انفصالها عن الاتحاد
السوفيتي في عام
1991 لم تخض بيلاروسيا حربا ويبلغ عدد
جنودها 48 الفا بين مقاتلين وموظفين
مدنيين يتوزعون على اربعه الويه ميكانيكيه
واربعه ادويه صواريخ ومدفعيه وضمنهم سته
الاف عنصر في القوات الخاصه وفي اسطول
المدرعات تمتلك مينز 400 دبابه من طراز تي
72 اضافه الى 1500 عربه مدرعه خفيفه و900
مصفحه ثقيله معظمها من الانتاج السوفي تي
اضافه الى 700 عربه خفيفه من انتاجات
روسيه وصينيه حديثه
[موسيقى]
وفي السماء يتمتع الدفاع الجوي البيلاروسي
بمنظومات تور وبوك واس 300 تعززها 65
طائره مقاتله من انواع 29 متعدده المهام
اختلال الميزان العسكري لصالح بولندا لا
يعني تفوق الاخير في اي حرب محتمله فرغم
التفاوت الكبير بعدد الجنود تمتلك
بيلاروسيا ورقه قوه حاسمه وهي صواريخ
اسكندر النوويه التي يخزنها الكارملين على
اراضيها صواريخ ان لم ترجح الكفه
لبيلاروسيا في الحرب فانها ستجعل الجوار
الاوروبي يفكر كثيرا قبل ان يشم اي هجوم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]